salut tout le monde j'espère que vous
allez bien dans cette vidéo je vais vous
parler d'un sujet extrêmement difficile
c'est les crimes de guerre de l'armée
russe en ukraine je vous préviens il ya
énormément d image très choquant à
regarder dans ce reportage et qui
peuvent heurter la sensibilité de
certaines personnes mais c'est la
réalité de ce que j'ai filmé sur place à
partir de la fin du mois de mars 2022
les troupes russes se sont retirés de la
région actifs mais pendant plusieurs
semaines ils ont contrôlé des villes et
des villages dans lesquels ils ont
commis des atrocités quelques jours
après la libération de cette zone je
suis parti sur place avec mes fixeur
pour rencontrer les ukrainiens et les
ukrainiennes qui ont vécu l'occupation
il ya énormément de personnes qui
essaient de s'échapper en voiture des
civils avec des enfants etc qui se
faisaient tirer dessus les troupes
russes et il ya énormément de voiture
sur le bas-côté avec la carrosserie
complètement défoncée et à des impacts
de balles partout
donc là je viens d'arriver un ancien
chef militaire russe sur la route de
borodianka qui a été attaquée par
l'armée ukrainienne est repris et les
combats ont été extrêmement violents
une dizaine de chars de véhicules
blindés vue
qui ont été détruits par l'armée
italienne
est aussi un camp dans la forêt
ils ont dû faire des pillages parce
qu'il ya de la nourriture et craignons
donc ça c'est un chariot par exemple
qu'ils ont dû remplir dans un
supermarché une craignent un et qu'ils
ont entraînés ici jusqu'à leur camp
beau come back en attaque pour la
plupart des tanks qui a été un cadavre
complètement carbonisés des soldats
russes qui ont été tuées pendant ces
combats the first baril
[Musique]
j'en arrivais dans une grande base qui a
été abandonné il ya seulement quelques
jours par les soldats russes elle se
trouve à un croisement stratégique et
vous allez voir devait y avoir beaucoup
de soldats parce qu'il ya énormément de
construction qui était en cours et ils
ont tout laissé en plan
là quand je me déplace à vue que je ne
sais pas si ça a été démis né ici je
regarde où je mets les pieds surtout
j'essaie de marcher dans les traces des
véhicules s'il ya moins de chance qui
est des mines à cet endroit là où en
tout cas ils les auraient déjà fait
exploser si son passé dessus
dans beaucoup de check point qui
contrôlait les russes ont creusé des
tranchées
des planches en bois sont complètement
neuve
et c'était à
anticiper une contre-offensive
ukrainienne et pouvoir se protéger des
attaques
et des rations de combat russe
s'était même fait un endroit pour dormir
ça veut dire qu'il y avait des soldats
qui étaient postés là 24 heures sur 24
pour surveiller à ce point de passage
il ya des douilles de balles un peu
partout
elles ont creusé des trous profonds
comme ça
pour se protéger en cas de bombardement
de tirs de mortiers d'obus
au dessus de chaque trou il recouvrait
saad arbres
ce soit plus difficilement détectables
c'est impressionnant par exemple
construit tout ça en moins d'un mois
mais c'était un très gros tchèque
politiciens
ils ont creusé un trou juste derrière
moi il devait y avoir un engin motorisé
peut-être un tank peut voir des traces
il y avait des branches juste ici c'est
bon elle devait servir à recouvrir
l'engin qui était juste là
tout à l'air encore très intac n'a pas
l'air d'avoir eu de combats ici mais
tout est resté tel quel
il ya des planches de bois un peu
partout il avait découpé il était en
train de commencer à construire des
choses donc
ça donne l'impression qu'ils sont partis
en vitesse de cet endroit et qu'ils ont
tout laissé sur place
sur la route et dans les petites villes
qu'on a pu traverser on a vu à quel
point les russes étaient partis
rapidement du jour au lendemain pour se
replier à l'est du pays on a croisé
plusieurs bases plusieurs check point où
ils ont tout laissé en plan après faut
savoir que la plupart du temps l'art
mink ligne n une fois qu'elle a libéré
certaines zones elle est née toi c'est à
dire qu'elle fait des prisonniers elle
récupère les documents sensibles et en
général aussi à l'enlève les corps des
soldats ukrainien qu'elle a perdu et
russe
la plupart des petits villages qu'on est
en train de traverser un silence de mort
mais quasiment tous les magasins des
maisons
ont été endommagés par des combats
blog voici le clip possible on a moins
le pont du barrage de moiry un monde
empli
d'eau
en
[Musique]
fait la plupart des personnes qu'on
croise dans les vidal c des personnes
âgées avec une mallette là va être vite
on pouvait pas partir et qui ont dû
rester pendant l'occupation
je
voyais un mois d'autres
labos qui n'accepte pas les genoux
c'est souvent trop stoner mais elles
sont bon
voilà on ressort aussi ce que des tanks
et simon beaudry mais
aussi protéger
et vous pourriez aussi bon pendant
là on est dans la petite commune de
wortel jusqu'à côté de boudhha et c'est
un endroit qui a été contrôlé aussi
pendant plusieurs semaines par les
troupes russes donc il dormait dans les
maisons et pillé et ils ont tué beaucoup
de personnes des villageois veulent nous
montrer
après chaque crise
est en route chez toro rosso au goût de
guinée
fera demain je t'avoue dit did you know
disait bas
ce couple ils ont été tuées par balles
il ya deux impacts dans le dos du mari
et selon le voisin qui a assisté à la
scène il est expliqué que j'avais
interdiction de sortir de chez eux ils
n'avaient plus de nourriture donc ils
ont essayé d'aller en chercher c'est à
ce moment là qu'ils ont été tués par les
troupes russes matthew goode cette âme
automobile a dit qu'il était
vraiment être notamment face aux soucis
dernier pour
une fois que les russes sont partis
c'est là qu'on a commencé à comprendre
l'ampleur des massacres sur la
population civile on voyait déjà un peu
avant des messages de gens sur les
réseaux sociaux qui en parler ou qui
prévenait leurs proches mais en réalité
ce n'est qu'une fois que l'armée
ukrainienne à libérer ces villes et
qu'on a pu se rendre sur place qu'on a
réalisé qu'en fait tout le monde
connaissait forcément quelqu'un qui a
été victime des soldats russes pendant
l'occupation et c'est pour cette raison
que les autorités à uc régnait n'ont mis
en place une unité spéciale qui est
chargé de recenser les crimes de guerre
de l'armée russe et j'ai pu les suivre à
irbine une petite ville au nord de kif
où les combats ont été extrêmement
violents
l'arrivée
aujourd'hui de conduire
notre compagnie sur ce premier mois
complet
parties n'ont
pu vraiment soutien
troupe d'avoir attaqué péché
les civils qui sont ici ils ont été
enterrés par l'armée ukrainienne pendant
qu'il y avait encore des combats dans
les yvelines contre les troupes russes
et le travail des autorités là il est
hyper important qu'ils sont obligés de
les excuser mais pour recenser le nombre
de victimes s'assurer qu'ils sont bien
été tué par un bombardement et ça permet
de documenter les crimes de guerre de
l'armée russe
dos rayé me bourrer de mme odette jeu
non vous ce match à
brac prix en
[Musique]
ligne
ici on parle comme été aussi important
détachement
on ignore
aux victoires
de
la saison et
[Musique]
pour vous comprenez bien de comparer en
fait il faut que je vous explique
d'abord ce qu'on qualifie de crimes de
guerre en fait ce sont des attaques
délibérées contre des populations
civiles
ça peut être de l'enlèvement de l'
esclavage des violences sexuelles de la
torture des expulsions ou encore des
meurtres parce que dans un conflit il ya
évidemment des armées qui s'opposent et
s'affrontent mais il ya aussi quasiment
toujours des populations civiles au
milieu après la seconde guerre mondiale
plusieurs dizaines de pays avaient
décidé de rédiger des traités pour
encadrer le droit humanitaire
international
on les appelle les conventions de genève
il ya évidemment à plusieurs volets mais
il y en a un qui visent spécifiquement à
protéger les populations civiles et non
combattantes de toute violence et je
précise qu évidemment la russie à
l'époque l'urss avait ratifié ces
conventions de genève je reviens sur le
travail d'enquêté en ukraine parce
qu'ils commencent en fait déjà avoir des
résultats un premier procès a débuté
actif le 17 mai où un jeune soldat russe
est jugée pour avoir tué délibérément un
civil qui ne portaient pas d'armes il a
été arrêté par la minuk régnait alors
qu'il essayait de fuir la ville
je m'attends au pire
y en a retourné aux indiens à manger
trop
jeune
dans ce jardin ils ont sorti les corps
de quatre personnes et le dernier que
vous venez de voir c'est celui d'une
grand mère qui a reçu des éclats d'obus
dans la jambe et qui est décédé à cause
de sa blessure au moment où j'ai été une
unité spéciale récupérer plusieurs
dizaines de cadavres par jour et début
avril les autorités ukrainiennes ont
déclaré qu'ils avaient déjà retrouvé les
corps de plus de 1200 22 victimes
civiles rien que dans la région de kif
pression
maximum
moi je te voyais avait dit
au début du mois d'avril il y avait
tellement de cadavres que les autorités
ukrainiennes étaient obligés de les
répartir dans plusieurs morgue entre
l'ouest du pays et la région active pour
ne pas les encombrent et ensuite on a
continué notre route vers borodianka où
les bombardements russes ont été
extrêmement intense et c'est sûrement
une des villes les plus détruites par la
guerre dans la région stif
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de destruction un sancerre mercuriens
qui tient debout
selon l'armée ukrainienne clairement à
les russes voulaient faire des victimes
civiles quand on voit l'état de la ville
assez difficile de penser le contraire
cet appartement il a été complètement
détruit
il reste plus rien
tout le monde est parti
il ya des russes y ont dormi ici
il ya des restes de leur passion ils ont
essayé de pénétrer dans tous les
appartements mais vraiment partout des
tentatives d'effraction
les soldats russes sont passés par là
ils ont mis des tags et marquer vendetta
je vais m'entraîner à peu par des
appartements ils ont ainsi tagué lever
ces deux signaux de l'armée russe
là certains habitants sont revenus dans
l'immeuble juste pour récupérer ce
qu'ils pouvaient et ils vont quitter la
ville
pour déjeuner nous de pouvoir le
président nous valent même voir une
jeune le procès déjà la vigne est
malséant de voir le mieux pour toi hier
processus d'haïti mais retour
2 broyer des mauves la criminalité
volant
après borodianka on a décidé d'aller à
butch à vous en avez sûrement entendu
parler dans les médias parce que les
autorités ukrainiennes ont découvert un
grand charniers derrière l'église de la
ville où les corps de plus de 65
personnes ont été exhumés
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
un charnier comme celui ci c'est une
véritable scène de crime donc c'est pour
ça qu'il ya des enquêteurs il ya la
police scientifique qui essayent de
récolter un maximum de preuves pour
peut-être retrouver les responsables qui
ont commis ces atrocités mais ils sont
aussi là pour essayer de retrouver des
affaires des effets personnels pour
confirmer l'identification de la
personne et ensuite rendre le corps à la
famille
fisher
lors
d'un discours
avait il besoin de vous baigner mais moi
je t'aime il vit donc ce qu'il que ça
m'a beaucoup marqué
les images étaient évidemment très
difficile sur place et on a notamment
croisé une grand mère qui pleurait la
mort de ses petits enfants et de sa
belle-fille qui ont été tués alors
qu'ils essayaient de fuir la ville
[Musique]
en août les putschistes
guinéens ouellette a couronné une taxe
reste rien
calmé la tête de cochon ce n'est pas
d'ailleurs
[Musique]
j'espère que ce reportage vous a
intéressé je sais encore une fois que ce
sont des images très difficile à
regarder mais je pense sincèrement qu'il
faut qu'elles existent pour qu'on ne
puisse pas nier ces crimes ça me
rappelle évidemment les reportages que
j'ai pu faire sur les crimes de guerre
de l'état islamique en irak et en syrie
et voilà je maintiens que ce travail de
documentation il est primordial est
indispensable j'en profite aussi pour
vous dire que début juin sur la chaîne
youtube il y aura le témoignage très
fort d'un reporter ukrainien tiède les
journalistes étrangers sur place se fixe
heures a été enlevé et torturé par les
soldats russes pendant plusieurs jours
il a accepté de me raconter ce qu'il a
vécu fixeur c'est d'ailleurs le titre de
mon prochain docu qui sort sur brut x le
8 juin et dans lequel vous allez
entendre pour la première fois ces
hommes et ces femmes sans qui je ne
pourrais pas travailler sur le terrain
merci encore pour tout votre soutien
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à la chaîne
youtube de brut pour ne pas rater la
prochaine vidéo a très vite
[Musique]